in a boyish smile rebellious hairstyle
and a loving Liverpudlian accent it's
genius in extended beyond music to words
play and visual arts while he excited
and inspired teens he frightens parents
and pastors and was a target of the
Nixon era FBI who was this British
phenom well that would be the inimitable
John Lennon
[Music]
with bombs falling around the hospital
John Lennon was born on October the 9th
1940 in the midst of World War two his
mother Julia gave him the middle name
Winston in honor of Britain's leader at
the time his father Alfred was a
merchant marine and was absent John's
birth meze would be for much of John's
childhood Lennon's childhood was
unsettled with an absent father and
mother who simply couldn't handle the
motherhood after the age of four Leonard
didn't even live with his mother instead
living with his childless uncle George
and aunt Minnie the two were a stern but
loving influence on Lennon throughout
his childhood though Minnie did what she
could to discourage Lennon's love of
music it was she who famously told him
the guitars all very well John but he'll
never make a living out of it Lennon's
mother was more supportive of his
musical interest in fact it was Julia
who bought the guitar for him though
Denon didn't live with his mother he
remained close to her regularly visiting
a house where the two would listen to
Elvis records and pluck chords on the
banjo ukulele and the guitar Julia was
also a frequent visitor at her sister's
house where she spent morning's drinking
tea with Minnie and chatting with her
son after one of these prank war visits
unfortunately tragedy struck as Julie
across the street to head home one day
she was struck and killed by a passing
car John was 16 years old when his
mother died and he carried the weight of
the tragedy with him for the rest of his
life at the time Julia died Leland was
already having trouble in school he was
smart no doubt about that but his wit
and attitude got him into trouble with
teachers he created comics of teachers
and fellow students in a work he titled
The Daily howl and detention sheets from
Quarry Bank high school show that Lennon
at once received three detentions in one
day with offenses over the years ranging
from fighting in class to sabotage to
just no interest whatsoever while he was
goofing off in school Lennon was paying
close attention to his music Lennon was
playing in a band called The Quarrymen
and he was one of this bands gigs that
would ultimately lead to the formation
of the Beatles on July the 6 1957 the
quarry man played the Wilton village
fete and one of Lennon's bandmates
decided Lennon should be introduced to a
friends of his and swelled he was that
friends well he might have heard of him
that friends was Paul McCartney that
in McCartney who was two years john's
jr. taught lenin how to tunicates morons
impressed him with a rendition of the
song 20 flight rock the atmosphere of
the day stuck with Paul even if the
exact here didn't a Walton village fate
I met him I was a fat schoolboy and he
leaned an arm on my shoulder I realized
he was drunk we were 12 then but in
spite of his sideboards those sideburns
we went on to become teenage pals it was
only two weeks before Paul was asked to
join The Quarrymen band he agreed
shortly thereafter Paul introduced John
and the other band members to his friend
George Harrison it was 1958 and three of
the four Beatles had already found each
other but music couldn't be John's only
focus though he had failed his exams
upon leaving high school Lennon's arms
and former headmaster pulled strings and
persuaded the Liverpool College of art
to accept to the rambunctious teen who
did show incredible promise in the arts
Lennon started attending the Liverpool
College in art in the fall of 1957 Oh
Alan didn't fare much better in art
school than he had in traditional school
though he did meet his first wife
Cynthia Powell Len Ernie never had the
right equipment for his classes and was
always borrowing Powell's tools
it was also up to Powell to help Lennon
through his exams which she ultimately
fails for all the help she gave him
Lennon was not a kind and loving
boyfriend to Powell in fact he could be
downright abusive even acknowledging as
much by later saying I was sort of in a
blind rage for two years and we see the
drunk or fighting it had been the same
with other girlfriends at hat there was
something the matter with me the
relationship lasted though and in 1962
Powell discovered she was pregnant with
Lennon's Charles in keeping with the
expectations of the time the two were
married in a simple civil ceremony in
Liverpool Lennon's music career had
already taken priority over all else
finest points and they skipped a
honeymoon so he could play a gig the
night of their wedding
Cynthia gave birth to Julian Lennon in
1963 and with the beatles star on the
rise in Liverpool John didn't pay much
attention to his son in fact his
relationship with his son was no better
than it was with his wife something
Julian publicly and angrily spoke about
as an adult he stated
dad could talk about peace and love out
loud the world but he could never show
it to the people who supposedly meant
them
his wife and son how can you talk about
peace and love and have a family in bits
and pieces no communication adultery
divorce John was the only married weasel
and the only one with a child
and the group's manager tried to keep
this information about Lennon under
wraps as he marketed the group girls
wanted their pop stars to be single and
cute not married
[Music]
The Beatles rise to fame began at the
cavern club but it was in dispersed with
performances in Germany along with the
Lennon McCartney and Harrison bandmates
Stu Sutcliffe and P best made up the
band's lineup for their infamous stays
in Hamburg Germany at the Kaiser Keller
Club the boys no more than 22 and George
Amy 17 lived in horrid conditions and
survived on only pills and alcohol
during their stay
but the audience's they loved them
especially lemons onstage antics one
night he was supposed to be on stage but
instead was fooling around with a woman
and the two only broke up when the
club's bouncer dumped cold water on them
instead of getting dressed to go on
stage Lennon grabbed his guitar and
joined his bandmates only wearing
underwear and a toilet seat around his
neck when the Beatles returned to
Liverpool and resumed playing at the
Cavern Club
they caught the attention of a young
record store owner in the area familiar
with the group from their visits to his
store Brian Epstein went to one of their
performances where he saw their
potential and signed on as their manager
he got them a record contract and was by
their side until his death in 1967
Epstein was gay and homosexuality was
still illegal in England during the
1960's over the years rumors have
persisted that Lennon Epstein had an
affair largely stemming from a vacation
the two took together in Spain in 1963
mere weeks after his son was born Lennon
denied the rumours saying I was on
holiday with Brian Epstein in Spain
where the rumours went around that he
and I were having a love affair it was
almost a love affair but not quite
it was never consummated but it was a
pretty intense relationship by early
1964 The Beatles were hitting the
airwaves in America then on February the
7th 1964 their plane touched down at the
newly renamed Kennedy Airport in New
York City crowds of teenagers greeted
them hanging over the railings screaming
and waving signs when they made their
way through the crowds to speak to the
press Lennon treated the American media
to a dose of his classic wit when a
reporter asked why people love the
Beatles so much Lennon replied if we
knew we'd form another group and be
managers two years later the last from
Liverpool made their first appearance on
The Ed Sullivan Show as the studio
audiences screamed and 73 million
Americans watched from home
The Beatles performed five songs during
the show each Beatles name at the
on the screen then ins name had an
addendum though it read sorry girls he's
married
giving Cynthia and Julia's existence
quiet was not possible for a man who was
about to become one of the most
recognizable people in the world
[Music]
1964 it saw the release of both the
movie and the album a hard day's night
marking all four Beatles foray into the
film industry Lennon would later appear
in a satirical film called how I won the
war not to be constrained by only two
artistic mediums though Lennon also
published a book in 1964 entitled in his
own right which he later followed up
with a volume entitled a Spaniard in the
works as the 60s continued on the
Beatles stayed at the top of the pop
culture world and that high profile
meant that a Lennon's mouth could get
him and the band into trouble pretty
easily in 1966 he famously told a
reporter that the Beatles were more
popular than Jesus when the remark was
published it caused an uproar
[Music]
so-called Beatle burnings were held
around the United States during which
teens and their parents burned albums
photos and other Beatles memorabilia
1967 was the year that the Beatles took
a rock-and-roll to new heights with a
release of sergeant pepper's Lonely
Hearts Club Band psychedelic concept
album that featured a collage of
historic figures and celebrities on its
cover initially Jesus were supposed to
be among those pictured in the artwork
but after Lennon's 1966 remarks he was
removed from the array one of the songs
on sergeant Pepper's was Lucy in the Sky
with Diamonds and it has long been
thought to be drug-related as the major
words in the title create the acronym
LSD
however Lennon said that his inspiration
for the songs imagery it came from one
of his favorite works of literature
Alice in Wonderland's
the overall idea stemming from one of
Julian's childhood drawings of a school
friend named Lucy during this time
period London began moving in avant
garde artistic circles primarily due to
his new relationship with artist yoko
ono he had met oh no which one of her
gallery shows and at the time at their
meeting consisted solely of her handing
him a card that said nothing but brief
on it though Lennon was still married to
Cynthia he and Ono began spending time
together even recording an album calls
to virgins that featured both of them
standing fully nude on the cover Lennon
and Cynthia did not officially divorce
until 1968 though the relationship
between Ono and Lennon was well-known
with earnest spending time in the
recording studio as the Beatles worked
and even lent her voice to the White
Album song bungalow bill in 1969 Lennon
and Ono married in a ceremony at the
Rock of Gibraltar an event that was
famously chronicled in the song The
Ballad of John and Yoko it goes like
this and no I'm not going to try and
sing it because you really don't want to
hear that finally made the plane into
Paris honeymooning down by the sin Peter
Brown called to say you can make it okay
you can get married in Gibraltar near
Spain while their wedding was a
relatively isolated affair they welcomed
the world to their honeymoon Yoko and
Lennon set up camp in a bed in the
Amsterdam Hilton in order to promote
world peace lying in bed fully clothed
for a week they repeated the stunt two
weeks later in Montreal and it was at
the Montreal bed in that they recorded
give peace a chance
surrounded by men
of the press and other friends and
followers by this time that Lenin was
fully dedicated to his life with Ono and
each of the Beatles had started to move
in their own directions oh no its
presence in the recording studio Manta
input on the music to the other Beatles
and they also had begun exploring
different artistic worlds the
disintegration of the world's most
famous band well it had begun Lennon was
the first of the Beatles to tell them
that he was leaving the group and he did
this in September of 1969 but it was
Paul McCartney who broke the news to the
world publicly that he was leaving and
the Beatles officially split on April
the 10th 1970
[Music]
though he had left the Beatles behind
Lennon did not abandon music his first
post Beatles album was released in 1970
with many of the songs inspired by the
primal scream therapy he had begun
practicing as a method of dealing with
the trauma he had experienced in his
childhood the song that perhaps most
demonstrates the influence of primal
scream his mother which includes the
lyrics mother you had me but I never had
you I wanted you you didn't want me so I
I just got to tell you goodbye goodbye
by the time then released his next solo
album he and Ono were living in the
United States settling into the
luxurious Dakota apartment building in
New York City it was here that he ropes
the most iconic of his solo works and
that would be imagine the song and the
album they were huge hits in nearly 40
years after Lenin's death the song
remains an international anthem of peace
and love now no no no no they enjoyed
living in New York City but the US
government did not enjoy having the
counterculture icons in the midst of the
largest American metropolis in 1972
18-year olds would have the right to
vote for the first time and eighteen
year olds they listened to John Lennon
when they sang and spoke about the evils
of war and the actions of the government
that made him a threat to Richard
Nixon's re-election and in 1972 the
government revoked Lennon's visa based
on these fears they threatened
deportation and not wanting to be
separated from Ono Lennon essentially
stopped his involvement with
countercultural activities but as
threats of deportation continued Lennon
was forced to hire attorneys and
continuously appeal to stay in the
country in 1976 only after the Nixon
presidency fell apart under the pressure
of Watergate did Lennon receive his
green card and was safe to stay in the
United States during this struggle to
obtain his green card Lennon was also
struggling with his relationship with
Ono the two essentially separated for
over a year and Lennon even moved out to
California to live with a former
secretary May pang with whom Ono had
encouraged him to begin a relationship
Lennon later refer to this period of his
life as the Lost Weekend as it was
fueled by alcohol and drugs and marked
by aggressive behavior from Lennon he
once even trying to strangle pang and
got thrown out of a club fed drunkenly
heckling the
as brothers from Lenin's absence Ono
realized that she needed him in her life
she ultimately came to blame society's
pressures and not him telling playboy
Don was a fine person
it was society that had become too much
I'm thankful to John's intelligence that
he was intelligent enough to know this
was the only way that we could save our
marriage
not because we didn't love each other
but because it was getting too much for
me
when the two reunited who quickly became
pregnant she gave birth to Sean Lennon
on John's 35th birthday on October the
9th 1975 with the birth of Sean came a
sea change in Lenin's life where he had
been an absent father to Julian he was a
doting father to Sean
giving up music and instead spending his
time as a househusband Lennon orcid
again spending time with Julian again
during the 1970s Julian visited New York
and anden taught his first son guitar
techniques for five years Lennon focused
on domestic life but by 1980 he felt the
tug of the artistic muse once again he
began writing songs recording an album
and officially re-entering the music
scene with the release of Double Fantasy
in the fall of 1980 John Lennon well he
was back
[Music]
but his return to music well it was not
to last two months after Double Fantasy
was released Lennon and Ono headed to
the recording studio to work on new
songs that they had written on their way
to the studio then and stopped to sign a
copy of Double Fantasy for Mark David
Chapman a fan who was waiting outside
the Dakota on their return shortly
before 11:00 p.m. Chapman was still
waiting outside the Dakota building as
Lennon and Ono walked by Chapman pulled
a gun and fired five shots at Lennon and
hysterical Ono called for help and the
NYPD arrived officers loaded the wounded
Lennon into the back of a cruiser and
drove him to the Roosevelt Hospital well
their efforts they were fruitless John
Lennon was declared dead on arrival at
11:00 p.m. December the 8th 1980 the
United States heard the news via Monday
Night Football broadcast and the news
quickly made it to the rest of the world
crowds began to show up at the Dakota
singing Lennon's songs and carrying
signs in his memory
no funeral was held instead Ono had his
body cremated and scattered his ashes in
Central Park the location now called
Strawberry Fields is a memorial
dedicated to Lennon that is visited by
legions of fans every year John Lennon's
public life was dedicated to art and the
promotion of peace but his private life
was quite a bit more complicated and
dramatic what is certain is that there
is no doubt that he holds a special
place in the lives of those who grew up
with him and his music as well as the
children and grandchildren of those baby
boomers who have come to love his music
and his legacy a groundbreaking musician
an experimental artist Lennon turned his
private pain into beauty for the world
his legacy has lived on for decades
after his death and surely will continue
to live on long after we're all gone so
I really hope you found their video
interesting if you did hit that like
button below and don't forget to
subscribe we put out to Baia graphics
videos every week also check out some of
the other ones that I'm linking to on
the screen now and as always thank you
for watching